So Tommy Robinson, to all your cronies,
Danny Tommo, Liam Tough, Tommy Robinson,
and you all of you intellectual flipping
midgets, I challenge you guys. Come face
to face with me. I will come to where
you are anytime, any place for a
dialogue, for a discussion or you know
where I am. You know where I am in
Leicester Square. Come to my table like
a civilized people. Let's debate and I
dare you to prove me wrong and I will
give you 10,000 pound cash. I will
borrow that money and I will give it to
you.
>> I'm so happy to be able to talk to you
today and mashallah my brother our Ali
Hammuda is doing a great job. Work
forever is a very very uh beautiful
cause because the reward of what you
give is not just at the moment of giving
but rather it is prolonged for a very
very long time and it lasts for as long
as that work continues to generate to
generate some form of benefit. So I
highly recommend walk forever as an
ambassador of Abdullah Aid. I know the
the uh partnership that we have is
amazing and uh not many people
understand the concept of wak yet the
reward is far greater through the wak.
So inshallah if you can support forever
uh it will be really really amazing and
very very rewarding. Asalam alalaykum
two brothers and sisters and dear
friends and I'm sure there's going to be
a lot of far right watching this and I
would like to say hello guys how you
guys doing hope you guys are well you
know your uh day-to-day Islamist
jihadist Ali Dawa is here as you guys
can see you know Islamism and Islamist
and jihad and you know they call me all
kinds of starts no call me Ali jihadi
Ali daw jihadi or ali jihad dawa or
jihad ali dawa whatever you guys would
like to make up and call anyways let's
get straight to the point this is a
£10,000
challenge to Tommy Robinson £10,000 do I
have that money know, I've got maybe
£1,500, something like that in my bank,
maybe. But I would find the money from
somewhere. And the reason I'm making
this challenge is cuz I know you will
never ever be able to do that. And you
can usually I would not want to give
money to someone like you, you know, cuz
you're going to spend the money on
cocaine, prostitutes, or give it to IDF
who are killing innocent men, women, and
children. So that's I mean, if it was
something like that donated towards me,
I would give it towards Christians,
Muslims, anyone who's in a
povertystricken country to help them. So
that's the funny part about it. But
anyways, £10,000 challenge to Tom
Robinson. Uh this little intellectual
That's what he is. When I mean
he's actually uh short as well. There's
short people as well. There's Muslim
short people. There's nothing wrong with
that. But this guy's an intellectual
Yes, he has no intellectual
capacity at all. So he said, which we're
going to watch the video. And not only
that, a Rashid, Shikhar Rashid, which I
have respect for. I have my
disagreements with that's different
topic. We're not here to talk about
that. He also called him out. And I
believe she assided you should leave
these little midgets on the road. these
little peasants, these little clowns to
people like us. Your peer grade is too
high. Like I believe actually it's like
someone like you yourself. It's like
Muhammad Ali challenging some person on
the road for a match. Tommy Robertson
and this dirt bags like them. Leave them
to us. I've confronted him before when I
saw him in front of the court. He was
actually when he saw me, it's like he
saw a ghost like the angel of death came
to him cuz he knows. So now what we're
going to do is we're going to watch
these reaction videos. So let's go to
the first one and let's see what Tommy
Robinson has to tell us because he's
read his own Quran. Surely he knows what
he's talking about and we're going to
dissect that. So here's the video what
he had to say. Then we're going to go to
the video of Shah Rashid calling him out
because he's lied against him because
he's is a known liar. He's also known as
a wife beater by the way. He was an
illegal immigrant in Canada and also in
Canada a woman testified that he went to
prostitute. He talks about sex
trafficking and he's a cocaine addict
and he supports a genocide. People who
are committ committing uh atrocities in
Gaza. So let's watch his video. Let's
see what he had to say. I'm sure he he
knows what he's talking about, right?
Let's go. I hope you guys enjoy the
video, guys. But before that, please
download the Salah Pro app. Brothers and
sisters, we are a charity. All of our
services on the app is for free. Free
kiblinder, no ads, free salah reminders,
encourages to pray, tells you salah
times. You can book a salah instructor,
a Quran instructor, you can order a
guided prayer map for absolutely free if
you want to learn how to pray salah.
Videos on how to pray salah, salah hubs,
and many, many more brother sisters. We
are not an app that shares your
information with third parties. All of
our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy
guys. Let's go back to the video. Let me
just explain to you how much of an
absolute Hums Ysef thinks you are.
Okay. A religion that says if you kill
one man you kill all of humanity. If you
carry read carry on reading that verse,
it says unless they cause mischief and
then they must be executed, have their
hands and feet cut off or exiled from
the land. The very verse is it 532 that
he's quoting and it goes into 533.
interested. I like it how he talks. It's
like he's like he's like a Muslim
scholar. He's he's giving us a tap and
he's explaining it now. Yeah, mate.
We're going to look into something. I am
going to give you £10,000 if you can.
What you're saying now if there's subst
if you can substantiate it. Yes. Okay.
You can't do it in the video. I'm going
to I challenge you. I will come. Look, I
I found you last time. I was looking for
I will come wherever you like. Anytime,
any place, any location, any weather,
bro. Anywhere. I dare you face to face.
And I did this with you. I asked you 20
times. Show me where in Islam we can
indiscriminately kill people because
they're disbelievers. You couldn't bring
one. So you're never going to take this
challenge.
>> He's taking you all for mugs. They
always do. No one ever picks them up on
it ever. Okay. So the verse that he's
quoting, "If you kill one man, you kill
all of humanity." Sounds pretty
peaceful, doesn't it? Unless you carry
on reading it. And then it says, "Kill
everyone." Yeah. Unless they cause
mischief. Now, has a Jew cause mischief?
In fact, what does mischief mean?
According to the lead Ibim Cathir, the
lead Islamic scholar from Saudi Arabia.
>> From Saudi Arabia. Yeah. Sorry mate. You
lived in the seventh century and there
was no Saudi Arabia in the seventh
century. You flipping What kind
of an idiot you are bro? You're absolute
idiot. Muslims are watching this and
laughing. I cathe in Saudi Arabia. There
was no Saudi Arabia back then. The lead
in the world Islamic scholar says that
mischief means not believing in an Ally.
So yeah, the Jew up in Manchester, he's
caused mischief. According to the most
renowned Islamic Sunni scholar in the
world, he caused mischief and the verse
that he's quoting says he must be
killed. Morons. pick them up on their
You can't lie anymore. We get
Islam. We understand it. We know the
instructions. You can't fool people. We
will pick you up on it. We're back on X
to embarrass you and humiliate your
lies, scum.
>> Okay. Interesting. So, he's exposed us.
We Muslims, we jihadists, we're we're
done. Okay. So, let's break this down
now. It's very important. So, what we're
going to do is now before we go to Assar
Rasheed's uh video, we're going to break
this down now. So he's saying mischief
means in the land that um if you don't
believe in Allah and his messenger.
Okay, that's interesting. But in surah
bakar verse 255 it says uh for example
there is no compulsion in religion. So
which one is it? Now this verse in surah
maida is not abregated. Not only that
inah chapter 60:8 where it says Allah
does not forbid you from being just and
kind to those who did not fight you
based on your faith and kick you out of
your houses to be just and kind to them.
And this is not abregated. Yes. Okay.
Cuz you make up the abrogation line.
It's not abrogated. I challenge you to
prove to me these verses were abrogated.
They were not. So now what's the point?
Hold on a second. Do we kill the Jews
because they're Jews and the Christians
and the Christians because of that
nonsense? Because if that is the case,
why is it when Saladun ali and when they
conquered Jerusalem, they are the ones
who brought Jewish families. And when
the Christians were killing, the word
infidel comes from the crusaders. And
when they were killing Jews, because the
Jews killed their god, which is Jesus,
and they were were massacring them. and
the Spanish uh inquisition with Isabella
and Ferdinand where they were massacring
Muslims and Jews. So one second the
point is who did the Jews run to the
Muslim lands the Ottomans. So the
question is if we are told to kill the
Jews and corruption means only it just
doesn't mean only that corruption in the
land of course it could be shik but it
doesn't mean that we are told that we
are supposed to kill Christians and Jews
because they are Christians and Jews
that is a fat lie. Now, let's go to the
Quran and read it in context. Here it
goes. It starts from verse 27. There we
go. And Tommy, the challenge is still
there. £10,000, mate. Yeah, you can
spend it on prostitutes. You know, you
can be an illegal immigrant in Canada,
go to prostitutes there. You can go snot
cocaine. You can go and um spend it on
massac genocidal people who are killing
innocent people. That's where you spend
your money. Relate to them in truth.
This verse 27. Oh prophet the story of
Adam and his two sons. How each offered
the sacrifice once offering was accepted
with the other while the others was not.
So he threatened his brother I will kill
you. His brother replied Allah only
accepts offering of the sincerely
devote. This is talking about Adam's two
sons. One ended up killing the other. So
it's talking about murder. If you raise
your hand to kill me, I will not raise
to kill you because I fear Allah the
Lord of the whole world. So his brother
saying if you want to kill me I will not
do the same back to you. Let's carry on.
I want to let you bear your sin against
me along with you along with your other
sins. Then you will be one of those
destined to the fire and that is the
reward of the wrongdoers. The next
verse. Still the other convinced himself
to kill his own brother. So he killed
him becoming a loser. So what we're
talking about is a murder. One brother
killing another brother. Let's go to the
next verse. Then Allah sent down a a a a
crow to show him how to how to do it
himself. Okay. So then this is why we
ordain. Now it's a peaceful verse. It's
going to get violent, right? Okay. Then
it says, "This is why we ordain for the
children of Israel, the Jews, that
whoever takes a life, unless it's a
punishment for murder or mischief in the
land, which we're going to come to
mischief in the land, it will be as if
he killed the whole of humanity. And
whoever saves alive, it will be as if as
if they saved the whole of humanity.
Although our messengers already came to
them with clear proofs, many of them
still trust after afterwards through the
land. So firstly, it's very interesting.
It's talking that this passage existed
in the Torah. It is directed to who? The
Jews. Now, we're not saying every Jew is
responsible for this, but what are they
doing in Israel? What do they justify?
They are justifying that they can kill
when Benjamin, you are connected to
Mossad. Mossad was connected to Mosad
Epston Island, the pedophile island, my
friend. Yes. And you are condoning that.
You saying Mosad, you got a t-shirt at
Mosad. Mosad's directly connected to a
pedophile island where little girls were
sent there to have uh influential people
to blackmail them. Do you support that?
You are your pedophile apologist here?
Let's ask a question. Now, this is
revealed to who? The children of Israel,
which are which are the Jews. They are
known for what? And I'm not saying all
of them, okay? I'm not saying all of
them, okay? We're talking about these
Zionist Jews, okay? So, they are ordered
what? Do not kill an innocent soul. What
did Benjamin Netanyahu and what does it
say in the Torah? Go to Amalachites. I
dare you to find a single verse like
this in the entire history of Quran
hadith. Kill men, women, children,
babies, donkeys. Okay. Now, the question
I want to know is why? What did a donkey
do? Like someone like you, like a
donkey. Yes. What did a donkey do?
Nothing. This passage is directly
telling you to kill anybody. So that
verse that you think that is in Islam is
actually in the Torah. Yes. And the
Zionist friends of yours are the ones
that believe that. So this was sent to
them. Now let's go to the next verse
where he says, "Oh, look where it gets a
bit violent." Let's read it for oursel.
Indeed, the penalty for those who wage
war against Allah and his messenger and
spread mischief in the land is death,
crucifixion, cutting off their hands and
feet on opposite sides or exile them
from the land. The penalty is a disgrace
for them in this world and they will
suffer tremendously in the hereafter.
Who is this talking about? You talk
about even kafir. Yes. Read the of this.
You jah, you ignorant. Yes. It's talking
about a group of highway robbers who
came to the prophet Muhammad who were
not well and ill. And the prophet
Muhammad sent them to his shepherd and
said, "Go to him. He has some medicine
and you will be better." They went there
and what did they do? They the the the
the shepherd looked after them. They
became well. Do you know what they did
to that shepherd? They cut his limbs
off, took his eyes out and crucified
him. So mischief in the land means what?
murder, highway robbery, anything that
causes disord disorder in the land
towards a Muslim or a non-Muslim, a vimi
who's under the protection of Muslims.
If he is harmed, the Muslim armies will
fight on their behalf. And the Muslims
have fought on the behalf of who?
Christians who were being persecuted by
other Christians. Why? And Jews who were
being persecuted by the Christians.
Muslims came to their rescue. But I
thought you said we can kill them just
because they're Christian and Jews. You
The 10,000 is there. You bastard.
I challenge you anywhere, anytime, any
place. I dare you to prove this to me.
The verse clearly says what? Crucifixion
and the capital punishment is for who?
Highway robbers in an Islamic state,
legitimate Islamic state. When a group
of family member is walking and people
come with guns and says money or kills
your family member, what are you going
to do? Pat them on the head and say,
"Hey, good one, mate." Islam deals with
it. Instead of saying, "Well, send them
to prison. Have hot water, hot food, hot
bed, PlayStation, and enjoy yourself."
Islam deals with it in the with a
capital punishment like the chop chop
square like your mate Liam Tu spoke
about. Yes. Okay. Which um if we think
about it many people agree that there
shall be a capital punishment. So now
the question I'm asking is very simple.
I thought this was about mischief in the
land that they are supposed to be killed
just because they are non-Muslim. bring
me a single verse in the Quran hadith
and Islamic literature that says we are
allowed to kill innocent non-Muslims
because they are non-Muslims my friend.
So the question is this to you now with
Tommy Robinson, you have identified as a
Christian. Fantastic.
My gosh. Oh boy. Oh boy. Your scripture.
Yeah. You're a Christian now, right?
You're a Christian now. Okay. Go to the
book of Psalms when it tells you to get
babies and happy is the one who smashes
baby against rocks. Yes. You dirt back.
You are someone that is supporting a
genocide of killing of men, innocent
men, women, and children. And you have
the audacity to tell us that our
scripture says that when the very army
that you support Mosad who's financing
the Epstein islands, the pedophile
island that you're you got connections
to and killing innocent people, every
accusation, like Sneo said, is a
confession. Every accusation is a
confession. So Tommy Robinson, to all
your cronies, Danny Tommo, Liam Tough,
Tommy Robinson, and you all of you
intellectual flipping midgets, I
challenge you guys. Come face to face
with me. I will come to where you are
anytime, any place for a dialogue, for a
discussion or you know where I am. You
know where I am in Leicester Square.
Come to my table like a civilized
people. Let's debate and I dare you to
prove me wrong and I will give you
£10,000
cash. I will borrow that money and I
will give it to you. I promise you. Mark
my words. Here's the challenge. If
you're man enough, do it. And this I'm
going to leave the video of Assar Rashid
Rashid calling you out. And like I said
before, trust me,
international like you. We deal with
him. He's too high paid for you, my
friend. With all due respect. Okay.
Okay. With all due respect, you
>> Tommy Robinson, you're taking my clips
out of context and the Nottingham police
found nothing wrong in that lecture. In
fact, you took the whole lecture out of
context for your following underbelly
following you. You do not even represent
the real English. If they went back to
that talk, they will understand the true
context. And now the police have visited
me uh to mention that you have provoked
extremists to take extreme action. But
let me tell you something. Your
extremism and decontextualizing my
videos
is going to go against you because
you're a liar. And I challenge you to a
debate on Islam. Debate me on Islam. If
you can't articulate yourself,
then bring your best academic from your
team and demonstrate that Islam is a
religion of terrorism as you proclaim.
Don't just take clips out of context. So
let me know when you're ready for a
debate or even if you have a single
academic in your group to come forward
and debate. Uh we can hold a debate in a
lecture theater if you know what that
is. You've been to the Oxford Union. So
come out and debate like a man. And
don't hide behind the Zionists who now
beat up women like Greta and make an
enforceer to kiss the Israeli flag. So
I'm a Sparkbrook man. You know where
Sparkbrook is. Show him Sparkbrook. It's
full of dark people. It's full of white
people. It's mixed. And we tolerate and
live in peace and harmony. And here we
have sparkle. There's a police incident
already. Look, turn the camera that way.
Police incident. This is the area I'm
from, Tommy. I can hold it both ways
academically. And the other way. So come
forward. And by the way, our brother
Sarhamdah in Instagram. Do follow him.
He gives daily updates about what's
going on in Gaza and about these
intellectual midgets like himself.
Inshallah. Brothers and sisters. Do
check his Instagram page as well. I'll
put that here as well. Brothers and
sisters, doing fantastic work. Till next
time, brother and sister. Inshallah.
Asalam alalaykum. The challenge has been
set. £10,000 is there. He will go dead
silent cuz he knows he's a flipping
liar. Okay? He knows himself. He's a
pedophile apologist himself, Mossad. And
he knows himself and he himself is an
illegal immigrant and he's the one that
actually supports the killing of
innocent people. We don't. We Muslims,
they are not our teachers. And nowhere
in our scripture does it tell us that we
should go and attack innocent people
just because of their faith. Till next
time.